bats are more like us than you would
think because they
live a really long time and that's
really unusual for a mammal of that size
so a mammal that size usually lives like
one to two years and bats can live up to
40 years which is amazing they have a
really interesting repair mechanism for
their dna
so they can repair all the dna that's
broken and they never get cancer
[Music]
bats are very resilient animals they
also have a number of adaptations that
make them very good at surviving in
harsh environments
[Music]
bats use loads of different senses so
bats use their eyes so they're not blind
but they also use sense of smell so they
have big smell regions of their brains
when they need to find food the primary
sense that many bats use is echolocation
or
sonar in human terms although the bats
have been using these signals for 50
million years we've been using them for
maybe 100 years
we also need to be operating on our
senses we have to operate on our gut
feeling a lot of the time jungles are
probably the best place for having to
use your senses constantly because
they're hot they're humid dark so you
almost feel bit like a bat very
claustrophobic and you have to be aware
of the little changes so when things go
quiet potentially as a predator in the
area
[Music]
bats very often live in very large
colonies very often these colonies
contain millions of individuals one of
the largest segregations of mammals on
the planet is a bat roost in texas in
bracken cave we don't really know how
many there are but it's between 10 and
20 million bats that live there this
colonial way of life has several
advantages so bats can sort of keep each
other warm reduce
energy costs by huddling together
another advantage of being in a group is
it reduces your individual risk of being
eaten by a predator so bats live in
large communities they have to get on
with lots of other people and on
expedition we can be in a large team so
building relationships sustaining those
relationships developing systems for
living in a community generally away
from normal society bit like the bats
and therefore we have to develop our own
ways of supporting each other looking
after each other
teamwork using the collective mind to be
aware of danger or to enable us to
actually do the tasks that we're going
to do
bats don't just care about their own
blood relatives they care about other
individuals in their wider community too
they form these buddy pears and if you
uh don't find a meal for that night
you can ask your buddy to share what
they have for that night and then the
next site you can reciprocate so it's
called reciprocal altruism one of the
very few examples of reciprocal altruism
in mammals in the entire world
so bats are often covered in quite large
numbers of um parasites bats get rid of
parasites in part by grooming not only
do they groom themselves but very often
they do something called aloe grooming
where individuals groom one another
proving some social bonds among
individuals in colonies bats are well
known for their personal hygiene their
levels of personal hygiene the dark dank
bits need to be need to be cleaned on a
regular basis and also you need to be
aware of your cleanliness around
particular around other people it can
ruin relationships particularly sharing
a temp with them for a period of time
and your ability to continue doing the
expedition
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video